hi everyone this is Jerry this is a live
blitz game I just put a seek out for a
seven minute game for Fisher random
chess or chess960 okay this is a game
against 21:55 player so let's look at
the arrangement that I have going on
here
I chose a seven minute game because
really have to do some considering in
the very beginning so I think we'll just
start out with this classical style
chests just uh place upon in the center
and it's already supported by this rook
I don't think castling will be that
difficult in this setup here probably I
guess nights before bishops rule Knights
in the corner probably not the most well
placed piece and already I could go
ahead and Castle just by doing one of
these things I'm not so sure if I want
to do that right away however so I'm
thinking maybe maybe connect the Knights
maybe play b3 and then see four just to
allow these bishops to bear down against
his likely kingside position because if
he's gonna Castle queenside in this
setup he's gonna have to really clear
out a lot of these pieces so let's see
I'm thinking maybe either be through
your b4 just to get this guy out
or maybe a3 and Bishop a2 might be an
idea I think eventually my knight will
want to come here let's see you guys
maybe I should do that first nice before
bishops let's just go with this so my
Knights are connected I'm probably gonna
play either b3 b4 and eventually maybe
even c4 maybe have two pawns here on b4
and c4 e castles I might as well castle
as well alright so this setup isn't too
bad my two rooks since they're here I'd
like to maybe push forward here and
maybe maybe there's the idea maybe
having my bishop along this diagonal is
best so maybe something like a three
bishop here and then b4 I think that
might be a good way to go about things
or maybe maybe just
maybe just break in the center right now
let's try this if he just captures I'll
just recapture my night so okay this
this square right here is probably going
to be very good and I'm I'm gonna be
playing this move soon all right so c5
this is now a hole in the black position
I'm not so sure I'll be able to make use
of it but just reacting to that threat
so already I have pressure against this
point alright so it takes I think I'm
doing better here because I have my
Knights out already and I have pressure
against this point right here so I'm
thinking of just taking taking first
because if I play b3 he could really
shut this bishop down b3 could be met
with d4 and then what do I do exactly or
maybe I do have something if I played b3
I'm hitting at this point and if he
plays d4 maybe I could push c3 and I
don't think he'll be able to maintain
this pawn I'm gonna try that b3 so my
bishop is already bearing down against
his King side if d4 I have to play C 3
so I have to be able to break through
like okay so d4 I have to be able to
crack through at this point otherwise
he's a big dummy in the corner so I'm
getting I'm getting my bishops out
they're functioning quite well I think
maybe exchange Queens first and then
capture here because if I capture here
right away
we exchange Queens well maybe that's not
so bad I have enough coverage on this
pawn right here my bishop and Knight are
watching over it so maybe or maybe even
queen out here maybe that's a try or not
let's let's just recapture the pawn here
not to get too sophisticated so okay
this is an open diagonal maybe I play
Bishop here to here now I want to just
have these bishops both hitting at the
the King right here so that's that seems
like it's a pretty good move maybe I
should just take take this Knight and
then try to work on making this guy bad
and that's for sure that would be a good
idea
let's just back up I want to maintain my
bishop hair I don't want to give up my
bishop hair in this sort of open
position
all right so reroute it this is a hole
that I'm gonna focus on this wasn't too
bad of a setup to have to cope with
centralized Knight my rooks are well
placed on e 1 and F 1 I think F 4 at
some point just to dislodge the central
night and it's just retreat so he's kind
of offsides you know unless he's gonna
be able to make use of this square I
think that he's really just going away
from all right let's just capture like
this F 4 is coming I think I have to
just kick this guy away F for this
Knight isn't so well placed I want to be
able to do something with my queen maybe
let's see Queen here to here that might
be a thought actually he's getting ready
to push f4 so I want I want to do f4 to
prevent that night here to here he might
be thinking about that could be annoying
if Knight here I think I'll play Queen
here yeah this night is gonna come here
and be a nice block hater of my this is
a passed pawn but it really can't go too
far I'd like to maybe get like Bishop
here Queen here to here b2 focusing on
this diagonal maybe that's a try
actually
so if night here Queen here and if this
Knight yeah I'm gonna do this so if
Knight here I could play here and then
there's there's problems along this
diagonal so my D is gonna be two maybe
even just play here with my bishop
actually if I play here then my queen
isn't seeing d4 directly he could play
here so let's get this night out of here
he's way too close in my in my territory
here I'm gonna get my King here cuz he
was getting if I if I chase the night he
was gonna go here and if I took twice he
had Bishop c5 and I'd be in a
a pin so I really don't want to allow
his night to come here how can I reroute
things maybe maybe rook here is a good
idea I actually get my Bishop working
first so if he takes here he'll end up
in a pin you could always push me away
or maybe before b5 is a good move here
Queen c3 is an idea I think right now as
soon as that Knight left I have a mate
threat I think he has to come back here
if he plays back here I'm gonna play a
four so I could play bishop here next
and not have to worry about b5 to chase
my bishop off of this light square
diagonal so what what is he gonna do
about this main threat he's got to throw
some piece in this way if Knight here I
could take and then he has to recapture
with this Knight maybe I'll do that if
Knight here I'll exchange rooks he lost
his connection okay
so he would he's he's back he has four
minutes thirty seconds
it's off night here I think I just
exchanged rooks he has to recapture with
this guy you know actually let's get
this guy here maybe I know he has to
watch over this pawn my Knights doing
nothing he's really just garbage
maybe rook here maybe there's ideas a
swing in the rook here taking on this
square I don't want to have to do this
I'm in defensive mode now so maybe Queen
here to here Bishop here you still can't
take this pawn right now alright my
Knights doing nothing for me if I could
get my knight working somehow maybe I'll
be okay so now here - here - here here
is that too far-fetched let's let's
support this point right here that's
really his only pressure I think it's a
knight here okay so my knight is making
a journey
III c4 here is where wants to get to
ideally so maybe here to stop Knight
here every
let's chase the Skyway do that to
support it let's hit this guy again I
want to make this guy flinch and he's
being very stubborn
let's back my bishop up and maybe try to
get on this diagonal again at some point
so he's kind of he doesn't have too much
maneuverability so I could just take
here or not
so he's threatening my bishop so now I'm
back to threatening this pawn again
we're gonna open file I don't need my
rook here anymore to watch over this
pawn so now there's ideas maybe Knight
move Queen here check and who knows what
I really want to I could grab this pawn
now that was a mistake
pretty sure cuz now not only winning a
pawn but I could come here where do I go
I'll just go here Queen here next maybe
do I have oh did I miss something I
could do night check queen out here
check check he missed it I think I'm
gonna go for this I'm gonna get my King
here this is this is kind of scary just
having this diagonal being in that in
the view of those two pieces so what I
do another repositioning maybe my rook
is best placed here
he's got pressure on me I don't want to
have to do that to my net with my knight
Oh
Fork what do I do here minute 30 let's
see if I take he recaptures I'm in a
fork not a good position to be in
Wow
alright let's try let's try this on push
get my bishop here rook here if he takes
with the Queen I'll come here with my
rook
okay this pawn is fine this pawn is
falling oh my goodness how many more
pieces could be hitting this this pawn
queen here Queen here ideas check this
pawn is toast
pick your favorite way to grab them I do
have two bishops bearing down against
the King if he moves this Knight he
could see that he's gonna get made it so
he can't take with the night
I've clean here check and then the King
I'll have to swing over here maybe or
have to block maybe this isn't a bad
idea
getting my Queen here what do I do next
maybe Queen here two here might be a
plan I always have to watch for this if
the Queen ever comes here he's got
discovered checks oh okay that's that's
not so great I think I am supposed to
come here now so now he's in a pen I
could maybe take this Knight if the
Queen leaves I can maybe play here with
my pawn let's get off of this file so
maybe maybe Bishop here I want to just
grab him or something so he's gonna fall
yeah okay let's just take him now what
here am I missing something I'll just
Bishop here what am I thinking bad news
right here he's gonna throw a check in
my Kings didn't have to come here Oh
Queen check
that'll do it miss that
ah trade Queens I guess this is game
over what did I do wrong I'm sure I
missed something it seemed - what do I
want to do I'm gonna get mated oh I'm
gonna lose my bishop if he takes my
bishop I'm resigning I think like I
could win it back
where's the technique he's gonna finish
me off
just let him make me I guess there's I
have poor position poor with time that's
all
there's the technique Oh Fork you missed
it I meant to go here mile slip why
didn't I take that pun I came there for
a reason
oh he would have got trapped if I did
that ah all right well it's time to
resign all right well that's all for
this video I hope be able to take
something away from it it's definitely
an interesting type of variant to play
that chess960 that number 960 comes
about from I believe there's 960
different initial positions where you
could arrange that back row
but again that's all for this video I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye